[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم
اوكرانيا تطالب بمزيد من الاسلحه وخطه
سلام على الطريقه الكوريه
انجلش
ضد المحتاجين في ايران والنظام يرد باحكام
جديده
هدفا
مع العائله ويستهم زوجه ابيه بتدمير صورته
[موسيقى]
تتباطا
ويبدو ان جميع الاطراف يعاني على صعيد
الاخيره والسلاح
خارجيه اوكرانيا
واقصر طريقه استعاده السلام والامن في
اوروبا
الى اوكرانيا وطلبت الحلفاء بان يحدثواها
ايطاليا مثلا تقول انها لم تتخذ اي قرار
بشان تقديم مساعدات عسكريه جديده
لاوكرانيا قبل فبراير وذلك لاعتبارات
تتعلق بالتكلفه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
الهجوميه على طول خط التماس في دنياك وهو
الخط الذي ربما يتحول الى حدود اوكرانيا
في المستقبل كما سنستعرض بعد قليل
القوات الروسيه تواصل
والحاق الخسائر بصفوف القوات الاوكرانيه
على خط التماس في سياق القتال المضاد
البطاريه في دوناتسك تم تدمير محطه
ايرادار امريكيه الصنع وايضا تدمير نظامي
تحدث الرئيس الاوكراني في الاردن
ارسالنسكي ان العام 20 23 سيكون عام النصر
وبنظره الى الاحداث مع انطلاقه العام يبدو
ان البدايه مبشرا لاوكرانيين اسلحه متطوره
امريكيه وغربيه في الطريق الى كياف صمود
وضربات ثقيله ضد الجيش الروسي على جبهات
القتال وتوحد غربي مستمر على ضروره دعم
اوكرانيا وتعثر عسكري متكرر للقوات
الروسيه طبعا اذا استمر عام 20 23 كما بدا
بحسب صحيفه واشنطن بوست فهناك فرصه جيده
لان تتمكن اوكرانيا من الوفاء بتعهد
الرئيس للعام الجديد باستعاده كل اوكرانيا
بحلول نهايته العامه او على الاقل مساحه
كافيه لانهاء التهديد الروسي بشكل نهائي
لكن على الجبهه المقابله يستغل الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين خطابات العام
الجديد لاعداد الروس لخوض معركه طويله
الامل مع زياده التحصينات وتعزيز بمئه الف
جندي روسي تم حشدهم حديثا امر سيزيد من
صعوبه المهمه على اوكرانيا وتحقيق تقدم في
23 23
سيزيد من صعوبه تحقيق تقدم اكثر من ما كان
عليه في العام الماضي رغم ان الخبراء
العسكريين يقولون ان الزخمه من الانتصارات
الاخيره يتصاحب
[موسيقى]
تنقل واشنطن بوست عن شكل فورد من مجلس
شيكاغو لشؤون العالميه قولها انه اذا لم
تتمكن من تحقيق اختراقات كبيره ضد القوه
الروسيه الراسخه والمتناميه فهناك خطر ان
تتحول الحرب الى صراع طويل الامد يصب في
صالح بوتن بينما يرى
القائد السابق للجيش الامريكي في اوروبا
ان التطورات في الاسبوع الاول من العام
تشير الى ان الافاق مشرقه بالنسبه الى
اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان ضربه مكيفك القاسيه
التي قتلت 89 جنديا روسيا بحسب وزاره
الدفاع موسكو يضيف او يقول ان ذلك دليل او
ان هذه الضربه دليل على ما يتفضل بها يضيف
بانه طالما ظل الدعم الغربي قويا فان هو
واثق من ان اوكرانيا يمكنها استعاده كل او
معظم الاراضي التي احتلتها روسيا هذا
العام بما في ذلك شبه جزيره القرم التي
احتلتها روسيا عام 2014 توقعات تبدو
متفائله بل متفائله الى حد كبير
ترجعون نجاحات اوكرانيا المحققه عام 20 22
في جزء منها الى سذاجه الاخطاء الروسيه
التي من غير المرجح ان تتكرر الان فيقول
خبير عسكري ان الدفاع اسهل من الهجوم وقد
اقام الروس بالفعل مواقع دفاعيه طويله اضف
الى ذلك ان كثافه الذخيره قد تنخفض من
الطرفين وليس من الجانب الاوكراني فقط
فهناك ادله مستمره على انخفاض الامدادات
الروسيه ايضا مسؤولون اوكرانيون قالوا
مؤخرا ان معدل نيران المدفعيه الروسيه على
طول الجبهه الشرقيه لا يتجاوز الان ثلث ما
كان عليه خلال الصيف ونقلت واشنطن بوست عن
مسؤول غربي تحدث خريطه عدم الكشف عن هويته
لمناقشه مسائل امنيه حساسه يقول انه رغم
ان روسيا امرت بتصنيع مكثف فمن الواضح ان
الانتاج الروسي لن يكون قادرا على مجاراه
الاستهلاك
ونتابع من ما يقوله مسؤول عسكري امريكي
الان تحديدا لا مؤشرات على تدخل بلا روسيا
في الحرب بل انها تكتفي بالتدريبات لكن
رغم هذا توقع ديمتري البروج وفيتش رئيس
مركز سيلفيرادو بولس سياليتر وهو مركز
ابحاث مقر واشنطن ان تكون اوكرانيا قادره
على استعاده بعض الاراضي هذا العام ولكن
ليس بما يكفي لتامين نصر النهائي الحرب
ليست عسكريه فقط بل هناك جانب اقتصادي مهم
وحاسم
الاقتصادي الروسي او الاقتصابان الروسي
والاوكراني سيتعرضان لضغوط شديده بمواجهه
حرب طويله ومن غير واضح اذا كان بامكان كل
دوله توليد ما يكفي من القوه البشريه لخوض
الكلب
حرب طويله اذا من شانها ان تؤجل الى اجل
غير مسمى تعافي اوكرانيا وسيتعين على
الحكومه الاحتفاظ بمئات الالاف من القوات
على الطول خط المواجهه الذي يقدر بحوله
1,000 كلم بينما يستمر الاقتصاد في انهيار
يعول الاوكرانيون وحلفاؤهم في الغرب على
شيء ما ربما يحدث في موسكو يقول هاتجيز ان
هناك بعض الصراعات الخطيره على السلطه في
موسكو بينما يرى البروفيتش انه بل يرى انه
رغم عدم وجود دليل فوري على اي تحدي لقبضه
بوتن الا ان ظهور معارضه كبيره في موسكو
قد يكون حاسما لكن في النهايه اذا تمكن
بوتن من تحويل الحرب الى حرب استنزاف
طويله فمن المحتمل ان يكون قادرا على
انهاء اوكرانيا كدوله قابله للحياه راويه
لذا يجب استغلال زخم الدعم لتحقيق ما وصفه
زينسكي بعامل مصر
طاهر ولكن امر اخر قد يصب في صاله الهدف
الاوكراني بتحقيق النصر وهو استنزاف
القوات الروسيه لمخزونها من المسيارات
الايرانيه التي تستهلكها بسرعه كبيره معها
الدراسات الحرب الامريكي كشف عن ان القوات
الروسيه التي تقاتل في اوكرانيا تحرق
بسرعه مخزونها من الطائرات الايرانيه
تحديدا نتحدث عن شاهد 101 وثلاثين وشاهد
136 مع استمرار المجهود الحربي واضاف مركز
الابحاث في تحليل محدث امس ان القوات
الكرام لان كفت من وتيره هجمات الطائرات
بدون طيار او في انحاء اوكرانيا منذ
ديسمبر ليرفع الضغط عن ترانته من الصواريخ
ذات التكلفه العاليه وقتا وشاهدا وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني
قال في تغريد على تويتر الجمعه ان القوات
الروسيه استخدمت ما يصل الى
80% من مخزون المسيارات مسيرات شاهد
الايرانيه ما يعني انه سيكون لدى موسكو 90
طائره مسيره ايرانيه الصنع تحت تصرفها فقط
[موسيقى]
جهاز الاستخبارات العسكريه الاكرانيه
افادت بان الكريم لن يتوقع شحنه اخرى من
طائرات شاهد بدون طيار والتي تم شرائها
سابقا على دفعات تتراوح بين 200 و300
طائره
اصبحت هجمات مسيرات شاهد سما بارزه في
الجهود الحربيه لموسكو في الاشهر الاخيره
وتم التغيير علامتها التجاريه واطلقت
عليها موسكو اسم غيران اثنين
وسطها كل هذا الضغط والقتال المستعر يشبه
السنتر الامريكي
الحرب في اوكرانيا بانها حرب خنادق بشكل
اساسي بل انها تشبه الحرب العالميه الاولى
تقريبا انها مروعه السيناتور كينج الذي
زار اوكرانيا مؤخرا اضافه ردا على دعوات
من بعض الجمهوريين بخفض بعض التمويل
لاكرانيا بالقول انه سيكون من الكارثيه
قطعوا المساعدات عن في هذه المرحله وتابعه
لوضع الامور في نصابها بالنسبه للامريكيين
يبدو الامر كما لو ان ساحلنا الشرقيه من
فلوريدا ثم غربا الى هيوستنكساس محتل من
قبل قوه اجنبيه وقد تنتهي الحرب بشيء
مختلف تماما عن كل ما ذكرنا الكلام
لسكرتار مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع
الاوكراني اوليكسيف دنلوب الذي قال ان
بلاده تلقت عروضا للدخول في تسويه للازمه
الاوكرانيه وفقا لصناريو تسويه الازمه
الكوريه المسؤول الاوكراني اضاف في حديث
تليفزيوني يعرضون علينا تسويه وفقا
للنموذج الكوري اي وفقا لما يسمى بخط
العرض 38 في هذا الطرف يعيش اوكرانيون من
هذا الصنف وهناك يعيش اوكرانيون من صنف
يذكر ان شبه الجزيره الكوريه تقع في حاله
من الناحيه الرسميه وذلك لان الحرب
الكوريه بين الاعوام 1950 و 1953 انتهت
بوقف اطلاق النار وليس معاهده سلام تمتد
المنطقه منزوعه السلاح على خط طول العرض
وتقسم شبه الجزيره الكوريه الى جزئين
متساويين تقريبا فهل نرى نسختين من
اوكرانيا غربيه وشرقيه
[موسيقى]
معنى من
كيفكو مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني
اهلا ااه بك معنا كيف يمكن التعليق على
كلام السكرتاير مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع
الاوكراني اولاكسي داني لوف الذي قال ان
بلاده ان بلادكم تلقت عروضا للدخول في
التسويه على الطريقه الكوريه همم هل هذا
ممكن ان يطرح على الطاوله
مساء الخير
شكرا على ضيفتكم وانا
بودينا العربيه كالعاده يعني كله اخباركم
وتعليقاتكم
وبحوث عميقه وتفصيليه
شكرا
مع السيد رئيس مجلس الامن
جوابه على كثير من الاسئله
الاوكرانيه بطريقه كوريه تمام
اوكرانيا من قسمه
للشبهين يعني شبه شمالي او شرقي
والغرب
320 يوم من الحرب
يعني يمكن ان تقدمها اوكرانيا
بهذا التوقيت بالذات خاصه مع اشتداد
المعارك يعني منذ قليل مسؤول عسكري امريكي
يتحدث عن معارك وحشيه تحصل في منطقه بخموت
وهجوم جديد على سوليدار
كل واحد بيعرف لان
مناطق دون باس مناطق مهمه جدا
حتى غنيه جدا
همم يعني همم ممتاز جدا اللي تستخدم فيه
فولاذ والى اخره وكمان همم الاراضي همم من
تقدم باس محافظه
غنيه
خام الحديد
باليوتيوب يوتيوب اليوتيوب
على الكره الارضيه
وتستخدم
لانتاج بطاريات حديثه
للسيارات ولطيرات والاخريه وفي اوكرانيا
من اكبر
مناجم اليوتيوب على فكره في العالم
يعني هناك امر واقع عسكري همم
تعترف به دول اخرى مستقبلا همم وقد تحجب
عنهم سلاح وقد تضعكم امام واقع جديد
فبالتالي ستضرون امام شوح المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه امام شحال السلاح ان تسلم
ولو بوقف اطلاق نار وليس بتوقيع على
الاستلام او على شامل الي والا لماذا يمكن
ان يطرح مثل هكذا فكره ولو كان ردا على
سؤال من قبل احد بمنصب سيدنا لوف
للاسف الشديد وفق لنتائج السنه الماضيه
اوكرانيا خسرت تقريبا 30% من ناتج الداخلي
مش معقوله ولو مش مساعده
لخلفائنا والجيراننا فكان من المستحيل ان
همم
شوفوا الخارطه العالميه روسيا اكبر من
اوكرانيا ب 38 مره مساحتا هي ذبيحه او جثه
يعني اربع مرات اكبر في همم
عدد سكان طبعا تفوق في عسكري واقتصادي
والاخره ولو مش مصادر
ماديه وعسكريه وتاييد العسكريه من الغرب
من اصدقائنا الجيراننا من ذلك وبعزيمه
الاوكرانيين ايضا ولكن لذلك البعض يقول
بانه اذا توقف ذلك او خف ستضطرون امام
الامر الواقع الى القبول بضم هذه المناطق
على الاقل مقابل تنازل روسيا عن تعرض لكل
اوكرانيا
الحرب
روسيا لا تزال تحت تقريبا
مساحه من الاراضي وكرانيه اللي تعادل
مساحه الامارات المتحده تتصور لماذا هذا
القرن 19 او قرن 21 اولا والثانيه همم نحن
لا نريد اراضي الغير لا ابدا ابدا
لذلك تعرض اراضي الاخرين للخطر عندما
اردتم ان تنضموا الى النت و الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي شعره روسيا بالخطر لذلك يعني
البعض يقول انه لاعب دور الضحيه من قبل
اوكرانيا لا ينفعها دائما لانها ايضا
تصرفت بطريقه انانيه بالنسبه اليها بينما
كان في امكانها ان تفاوض الروس وان تجلس
معهم على الطاوله لكي تمنع ان يتحكم الغرب
وامريكا على راسهم بمصير اوكرانيا واوروبا
زي ما يقولون العرب
يسرى على فكره كان هدف من ارداف
لبدء الهجوم الروسي ضد اوكرانيا المولد
بانهم
يخافون اوكرانيا سوف تندم الى خلف
ابدا
كانت حديث في اوكرانيا
فقط
روسيا ستغسل هذه السنه
1300 كيلو متر مباشره يعني حدود مع دول
حلف عطله
اول
مستشار وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه على رايك
ومشارك
باقونا معكم لنتابع ايضا في العربيه 360
مرشد ايران يتوعد المحتجين بمزيد من القمع
جديده تثير التنديدات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اذانات دوليه واسعه
لاعدام ايران متظاهرين والحكم على اخرين
بالعقوبه نفسها في انتظار التنفيذ اليوم
بكل العبارات عمليات الاعدام المروعه ايضا
الايراني
وبلجيكا كل هذه الدول استدعت الممثلين
الايرانيين فيما اعلن مكتب حقوق الانسان
الامم عن قلقه الشديد اتجاه اقتراب
السلطات الايرانيه من تنفيذ احكام الاعدام
في شخصين
وزيره خارجيه المانيا ان لنا بيربك ان
تبريره ايران احكام الاعدام بانها تنفيذ
للقانون امر مروع
انت
نظام القانوني الذي يتم بموجبه تنفيذ
العقوبات والادراج من ضمنها طلبت اليوم من
السفير الايراني الحضور الى وزاره
الخارجيه من اجل توضيح لا لبس فيه حول
القمع والترويع الذين يتعرض لهم
الايرانيون وكذلك عمليتي الاعدام
الاخيرتين واللتين سيكون لهما عواقب
اذا فما هو رد فعل النظام الايراني على كل
هذه الاذنات يا طاهر اصدار احكام ثلاثه
محتاجين جدد في محافظه اصفهان وفي وسط
البلاد بذريعه مشاركتهم في اعمال شغب وبعد
اتهامهم بالحرابه وبحسب بيان من القضاء
الايراني فان المحكومين بالاعدام هم صالح
امير الهاشمي وماشيد كاظمين وسعيد يعقوب
وبذلك يرتفع عدد الاحكام الاعدام على صله
بالاحتجاجات الى 17 تم تنفيذ اربعه منها
المتظاهرين بالخائنين ويؤكد انه من حق
السلطات ان تتعامل معهم بصراحه
[موسيقى]
حماده
كرم
مختلف اوروبا
المشاهد لي تظاهرات تحصل بايران طبعا كل
هذه التظاهرات بدات يطهر بعد مقتل الشاب
مساء اماني نستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي والى
الهوتفات في هذه التظاهرات الليليه تحديدا
في طهران
معصمي اخونا يا راجل السعوديه
[موسيقى]
الايراني 17 حكما بالاعدام اصدرها القضاء
الايراني على عجل في محاوله لقمع وتخويف
المتظاهرين لكنها احكام لن تاتي كلها على
ما يبدو نفذت العقوبه باربعه منهم فيما
ينتظر الاخرون المصير نفسه شباب
بطموحات عاليه ومهن متنوعه قررت محاكم
النظام الايراني الاقتصاص منهم مستنده الى
مقاطع فيديو غير واضحه واعترافات قصريه
اخذت منهم تحت التعذيب وفقا لمنظمه العفو
الدوليه
سرعت المحاكمات خلف ابواب مغلقه من قبل
لنظام المحكمه الثوريه الايرانيه لم يعطى
محامهم الفرصه للدفاع عنهم بل ان بين
الحكم وتنفيذه ببعض الحالات اقل من شهر في
دليل على ان هذه المحاكمات الصواريه
ومحسومه مسبقا
هاند محمد زاده 66 عاما بطلوا كما الاجسام
اعتقل في الثالث والعشرين من سبتمبر في
العاصمه طهران بعد مشاركته في احتجاجات
والتهمه باحراق سله مهملات واطارات وتدمير
قطبان على الطرق السريعه واعتمددت ادله
المحكمه على مقطع فيديو قال محامي انهم
مثبرك انكر المتهم الذي يعمل في محل
مجوهرات صغير في مركز تجاري التهم الموجهه
ضده بل ان اكثر من 100 موظف هو صاحب متجر
وقعوا على عريضه تضمن براءته لكن لم يستجب
القضاء للمناسبات حتى الان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اخونا
[موسيقى]
المصير
الذي اعتقل في اواخر اكتوبر في طهرانه
والتهمه بمهاجمه احد اعضاء البسيج بالسكين
واشعال النار في دراجه ناريه واتلاف هاتف
نقال وسندت ادله المحكمه الى اللقطات
فيديو منخفضه الجوده لا يظهر فيها سكين
بحسب منظمه العفو الغريب ان عضو البسيج
ورجل الدين اللذين قدم الشكوى سحباها
لمحاوله انقاذ صدرات من الاعدام بالفعل تم
تعليق حكم الاعدام بحقيقه قبل ساعات فقط
من الموعد المقرر لاعدامه فجرا لكن لا
يزال وضعه غير المستقبل
وبتوها من متشابهه تقريبا
حكم على محمد بروغاني ومحمد قبادلو سامان
صيدي وحميد قره حسن لو وكذلك ما نتشهر
مهما نواز وحسين محمدي جميعهم ينتظرون
المصير نفسه الاعدام شنقه
[موسيقى]
الشرطي قتل في مكان اخر حسب موقع الشرطه
نفسه اي انه قتل في مدينه الرباط كريم
ولكن نسبه الى ملف ابني هذا ما ذكره موقع
الشرطه عندما كان الشرطي ملقا على الارض
ركله الناس الا انهم نسبوه الى ملف ابني
حتى يعدموه كما قال الخطيب في يوم تشييع
جثمان القتيل كرمبور بانهم تجمعوا عليه
هنا وقتلوه هنا ما يعني انه قتل خلال
اشتباك وليس نتيجه لدارسه بسياره الجميع
يعلم ذلك لكن تعمدوا ان ينسبوه الى ملف
ابنه ليش نقوه هؤلاء يمارسون الظلمه انهم
ظلمه
[تصفيق]
مصير من ذكرنا حتى الان معلق على امل
التراجع عن احكام اعدامهم لكن هذه الفرصه
لم تتح لمحمد مهدي كرمي الذي اعدم في
السابع من يناير امس بعد نحو شهرين فقط من
اعتقاله في كراج التهما كرم بقتل احد
عناصر البسيج خلال احتجاجات في كراج
والسناده المحكمه الى الاعترافات القسريه
التي بثها التلفزيون الحكومي بحسب منظمه
العفو سيد محمد
ايضا في اليوم نفسه اي السابع من يناير
كذلك بعد حوالي شهرين من اعتقاله في اوائل
نوفمبر التهما بالجريمه نفسها التي اتهم
فيها كرامه قتل عضو في البسيج اثناء
احتجاجات كراج بعد زياره السجن حيث كان
محتجزا قال محاميه علي شريف زاد اردني على
تويتر انه موكله تعرض لتعذيب شديدا وضرب
بايدي مقيده
عينين مغمضتين ولكن على راسه وسقط فاقدا
للوعي وضرب بقديب حديدي على باطن قدمين
[موسيقى]
سبقهما محسن شكاري الذي اعدم في الثامن من
ديسمبر بعد اقل من ثلاثه اشهر على اعتقاله
كان اول متظاهر يعرف بانه يقتل في اعدام
رسمي وجهت اليه تهمه حرق سله مهملات وقطع
طريق وطعن احد افراد ميليشيا البسيج
وتهديد السلامه العامه تبعه الى المصير
نفسه مجيد رضا
رهناء ورد الذي يعتقل فتاسه عشر من نوفمبر
في مدينه مشهد شمال شرق البلاد
وشنق من رافعه علنا في الثانيه اكثر من
ديسمبر بعد اقل من شهر على اعتقاله كان
المتظاهر الثاني المعروف باعدامه رسميه في
مقطع فيديو وتم التقاطه قبل اعدامه وتحققت
منه وعائلته يبدو
رهن ورد معصوب العينين ويده مغطاه
بالجبيره قال لمراسل لا اريدهم ان يبكوا
عند قبر
[موسيقى]
بعد يوم من احداث اقتحامات انصار الرئيس
البرازيلي السابق يعيد برشلونه
قبل ساعات من تنصيب الولاده ويحكى الان
بانه يوافق تصريح زوجته انه وضعه يعني
مطمئن عنده مشكله في البطن اصابته اثناء
محاوله اغتيال سابقه
يا طاهر ما حدث اقتحامات قالت انها لم
تتلقى اي طلبات من الحكومه البرازيليه
بتسليم الرئيس السابق وفي البرازيل واصلت
الحكومه الاعتقالات كما فضت اعتصاما
لانصار فول سونارو في العاصمه
من يناير ثقيله في برازيليا راويه ذكرت
بيوم مشابه لما حصل في واشنطن هجوم منسق
على الكونجرس رفضا لنتائج الانتخابات هجوم
غذاه الرئيس السابق الخاسر يائيل البون
سونارو بسنطه الهجوم المنسق قاده انصار بو
سونارو على مبنى المحكمه العليا والكونغرس
والقصر الرئاسي غطينا ذلك باخبار عاجله
بالامس وبفيديوهات وصلتنا للتو- مشهد ذكر
باقتحام مبنى الكابتل من قبل الانصار
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في
السادس من يناير عام 20 21 لم يلبس الرئيس
البرازيلي الخاسر ببنت شفافه بعد الهزيمه
لكنه ودعاء انصاره قبل ان يغادر الى
فلوريدا بالدموع مصرا على ان احتيالا تم
لسلبه الرئاسه لكن وعقب الهجوم على رموز
السياده البرازيليه اليوم دانابول سونار
وبالامس دانابول في العاصمه لكنها نصف نعم
وقد وجد من خلالها طريقه ايضا لانتقاد
خصومه مره جديده كتب على تويتر يقول بعد
ساعات من بدء الهجوم ان التظاهرات السلميه
جزء من الديمقراطيه بموجب القانون ومع ذلك
فان اعمال النهب والغزو للمباني العامه
كما حدث اليوم عندما كتب ذلك وكذلك تلك
التي مارسها اليسار في عام 2013
و2017 كانت خارج القانون اذا شبهها
بتظاهرات اليسار السابقه
[موسيقى]
عقب ساعات من الهجوم تمت استعاده السيطره
على مقار السلطه البرازيليه لتطلق السلطات
القضائيه تحقيقات اوليه لتحديد المسؤوليات
في الهجوم بعدما تفقدها الرئيس الحالي
لويس اناسيو لودا سيلفا بعدما تفقد
المباني منجدا بما قام بهم او بهم
انقلابيون كما سماهم الرئيس اليسرى كتب في
تغريده على تويتر يجري التعرف على
الانقلابيين الذين اقدموا على تخريب
الممتلكات العامه في برازيليا وسيحاسبون
سنستانيف العمل في قصر رنالدو الديمقراطيه
دائما وقف اكثر من 300 شخص وطالبت النيابه
العامه بفتح تحقيقات فوريه لتحديد مسؤوليه
المتورطين في الهجوم على المباني رسميا
تلك وق وقد سلطات المنطقه قال احد
المتظاهرين ويدعى فيكتور رودريغيز نحن لا
نعترف بهذه الحكومه لانها غير قانونيه
واضاف لن نتراجع سنرحل من هنا لكننا سنعود
[موسيقى]
اللافته ان المتظاهرين استمروا بترديد
هتاف تدخل عسكري لطرد لولا من الحكم وهنا
استحضروا حديثا سابقا للرئيس السابق
بونسونارو حين قال في سبتمبر 20 21 ان
صبرا الشعب قد نفذ اريد ان اخبر اولئك
الذين يريدون ان يجعلوني غير قابل
للانتخاب في البرازيل الله وحده يبعدني عن
السلطه لدي ثلاثه خيارات السجن او الموت
او النصر وانا لن اسجن ابدا ثم قال بون
سونارو في يونيو الماضي ان هناك نوعا
جديدا من اللصوص من اللصوص الذين يريدون
سرقه حريتنا اذا لازم الامر سنذهب الى
الحرب فلا عجب اذا مما حصل استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في معهد البحوث فوندات
شاورجاس وهو يعير نيكولا قال كانو
لقد اشار الى جزء من اتباعه الاكثر
الجيولوجيه انه يدعمهم وانهم يفعلون ما لا
يستطيع رئيسهم الكبير القيامه به كان صمته
الشراره الرئيسه التي اشعلت الاحتجاجات
التي تحدث الان لكن الاكيد ان محاسبتهم
قائمه وزير العدل البرازيلي
والاعتقالات في حاله التلبس مستمره لانه
عمليا
او بعد ذلك بوقت قصير
وتتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا
السيسي يؤكد ان مصر تمر بظروف صعبه بسبب
الازمه الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
في بريطانيا اثارت مقابله الامير هاري
بالامس مع قناه اي تي في الكثيره من ردود
الملك القرينه كامله باركر كما اشار الى
تصرفات عنصريه قام بها شقيقه وزوجه شقيقه
مع زوجته
عاوز
الصمت ان يجعل الامور افضل بنسبه الى
الامير البريطانيه هاري جميع من خلف اسوار
قصر الباكينج تحت مرمره
سلسله معلومات خاصه له التحدث عن ويلات
حياته وانتهى بانتقاض ومهاجمه افراد اسرته
بينما الريح
مذكراته مثيره للجدل بعنوان
وزوجته والده
الملكسب المزيد من التعاطف
اعتقد ان الظهور في صفحه الاولى جاء من
اعتقاد العائله الملكيه بان التغطيه
الاعلاميه الايجابيه ستحسن سمعتك ميله
وفرص قبولها كملكه
بتبادل المعلومات مع الصحافه للحصول على
قصص ايجابيه مكتوبه عن نفسها لما كانها من
تحقيق لقبها
الحاليين من العائله والصحافه الصفراء قرر
هؤلاء الاعضاء التعاون مع الشيطان لاعاده
تحسين صورتهم
ثاني حاجه
الساحه لهاري لمهاجمه عائلته خلال سلسله
مقابله تلفزيونيه تسبق الصدور الرسمي
للكتابه
من التعامل مع زوجته لانها ممثله امريكيه
مطلقه ثنائيه العراق
الصحف الغربيه
لكن لقاءات الامير هاري كشفت ما هو اكثر
من مجرد خفايا القصر الملكي بعضها تصريحات
تناقضتهامات العنصريه التي طالت العائله
المالكه البريطانيه في هذا السياق قالت
المحلله وكاتبه السيره الذاتيه للملك
تشارلز
صحيفه القادمه ان الغضب من العنصريه
والثروه التي تمتلكها العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه قد ينهي قبول العامه بالنظام
الملكي في البلاد
واحولها كتاب الامير هاري وما ورد به ينضم
الينا من لندن عادل درويش المراسل المعتمد
في مجلس العموم البريطاني اهلا بك سيد عدل
يعني الامير هاري عندما استقال من مهامه
كامير ولديه واجبات ملكيه قال اريد ان
احمي نفسي وعائلتي من الصحافه الصفراء
والاعلام ولكن الان نلاحظ بانه اكثر من اي
وقت مضى هو تحت الاضواء يصرح باسرار
عائليه
وامور حصلت داخل بيت العائله هل
سينقل بالسحر على الساحر ربما
ويؤثر ذلك سلبا على الامير هاري في
المستقبل
من وجهتين الوجه الاولى
طبعا
يضر به داخل بريط
انيا بمعنى انه طبعا دي تصريحات من جانب
واحد كلمه ان الاسر الملكيه فيها ازمه
ربما مبالغ فيها شويه
ههه
لكن همم هو بيبص
لجزء اكثر يعني انا لاحظت مثلا في
المقابله وفي استخدامه
النهارده مع اي بي سي امريكا
اوروبا عندهم عاطفيين اكثر فهو طبعا يعني
عدد سكان بريطانيا كان مقابل امريكا
ومقابل اسبانيا واوروبا اللي بيبيع فيها
الكتاب فهو بيتجه من الناحيه العاطفيه
لهذا الجمهور للترويج للكتاب لكن انت عندي
حضرتك كثير جدا ان هو خسر جمهوره وخسرته
داخل بريطانيا همم استاذ عادل اهلا بك همم
انا اريد ان اسالك هل تعتقد بان التصويب
من قبل الامير هاري على الملك القرينه
كامله باركر تحديدا همم يعني قد يجلب له
بعض التعاطف بريطانيه واللي يحكينا قبل
قليل بانه فقط الكثير منه حاليا
هو يعني وضعها في اطار انا طبعا عندي
اولاد اكبر في السن من هذه واذكر موت ام
الله يرحمها واذكر عندما كنت محرر لاي ايه
ليلي وزي ما كانت امه بتعمل انا كنت فاكر
كمحارب الليلي في الجرنال وكان هي بتقول
انها اعتبرت بعيد عن الصحاب اضواء كانت
بتكلمنا بالليل
يعني يتميز بانه غير متعاطف مع الحصان
الملك
بعد ما قال عشان ترتفع الاضواء تكلمي تقول
الله ابعث المصور فلان براين هاريس لاني
باثق فيه هي نفسها وانا شاهد على ذلك
فهو فهذا الجزء من التناقض في ال- ال-
الشخصيه من ان هو عايز يختفي عن ابوابها
من ذلك ايضا موت امه ولد عنده 12 سنه دي
اثرت عليه
وهو مضطرب يعني هو عنده اضطراب عاطفي فعلي
وللاسف الزاويه بنت اكبر منه امريكا
لان اريد ان نصوب عليه دائما لديه الكثير
من الحق في امور معينه ان يكون لديه بعض
الارتباك ولكن هل تعتقد بانه القصر الملكي
سيقبل بتشويه صورته حتى لو استمر ذلك وما
باستعته ان يفعل همم باختصار لو سمحت
هو دي زي حرب غير متكافئه زي حرب العصابات
زي الجيش مش قادر يرد على الحرب عصابات
ليس لديه الادوات المتاحه على منشات
التواصل الاجتماعي على المنصات ال ال ال
ال ال ال الميديا همم
الرسمي كالعاده يعني مثلا
هو طبعا الصحافه
افتتاحيتها بتعكس وجهه نظر قراءها هي ضد
الاميره
شكرا جزيلا استاذ عادل درويش المراسل
المعتمد في مجلس العموم البريطاني شكرا
جزيلا لك اليوم في العربيه 360 من مكتبه
في العاصمه البريطانيه لندن
الاحتياطي وذلك بنصف ثم فقط
في جميع وسائل الاعلام البريطانيه
والعالميه وذلك بعد تسريب النسخه
الاسبانيه من الكتاب قبل الموعد الرسمي
للنشر بخمسه ايام وربما يوجد سبب اخر وهو
استطلاعات الراي التي تظهر ان معظم
البريطانيين غير مهتمين بقصص الامير
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 للرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي اثناء مشاركته في احد
المؤتمرات في القاهره قائلا ان الحكومه لم
تدخل في اي مغامرات ادت لخساره اموال
البلاد لكن البلاد تعرضت للضغوط خلال ازمه
كورونا وبعد ذلك الحرب الروسيه في
اوكرانيا
في مصر صعب جدا مؤكدا ان الشعب يتعرض
لضغوط مشيرا الى ان مصر تدفع الثمن كما
تدفع كل دول العالم
فيديو اليوم في العربيه 360 من العاصمه
الهنديه ان يداله هي التي اصبحت غارقه في
الضباب اتلوت الشديد مع موجه برد اجبرت
السلطات على تاجيل المدارس وايضا تاجيل
العديد من الرحلات الجويه
ان يستمر الضباب الكفيف في اجزاء الكثيره
من دله والولايات الشماليه والشرقيه حتى
يوم غد
من هي العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار الساعه لا
تنقطع وتستمر
في جولتنا اليوميه سريعه الشامله
والمتنوعه اخبار الساعه العديد من الاخبار
اليوم طبعا على راسها الوضع الميداني في
اوكرانيا ولدينا المزيد حول قصه هاري
وربما اشارات في رغبته للمصالحه مع
العائله
[موسيقى]